well there aren't just shows reopening
on the strip there are also new shows
being added las vegas now's rocky theis
is live in studio with more hi rocky
hey brian yes there it was a very
exciting announcement today donnie
osmond said he is returning to las vegas
next year for his very first solo
residency he's going to be performing at
harrah's from august through november
tickets go on sale tuesday morning and
prices start about 65
and as some of you may know donnie
performed for on the strip for 11 years
with his sister marie
nearly 1 million fans attended their
shows when they were at the flamingo
but he made it very clear in our
interview today that this will be
completely
different i've been writing an album my
63rd album
and it's going to be a show trying to
encompass
six decades of music in 90 minutes
talking to the caesar's personnel last
night and
they said when you really get it right
down to it perez is our newest property
i said what do you mean because it's an
older hotel it's just no
wait till you walk through this i walked
through it last night
they have redone everything they
finished all the rooms redid all the
rooms as of january
the showroom is going to be redesigned
and updated the technology is going to
be completely different the sound will
absolutely blow you away the visuals
the plans that that we have for this
show
i can hardly wait to present it on stage
bringing new life to vegas and fun fact
back when donnie was about six or seven
years old him and his brothers were the
first act to open up harris tahoe so
donnie says and i quote
i'm literally back home you gotta live a
full circle moment right brian